hi there reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
John Humphrey we are gonna do a special
little video today been asked from our
top rewards here patron and good friend
David Gandy to do a pitch on how we
might remake the classic movie The
Godfather and Citizen Kane combined them
into a multi cinematic universe it's
been begging to happen for so long and
maybe you know leave an inroad to get
Scarface in there for the sequel I'm
always saying that these classics need
to be redone because they got to change
that word from classics is something
else they are not good highly these
Felisa Bulls oh wait he wants us to do a
touch of evil ok we'll do touch of evil
you know David actually sent us touch of
evil a few months ago
it's blu-ray copy and when it came time
to play the movie of the other day is
the first time you hadn't seen it before
right I've seen chunks of it but this is
the first time I've seen the full movie
yeah there it was your first time
watching it is what you're saying
I yeah I mean in full I knew this story
I've seen a lot of it in film school but
this is the first time like yeah
watching it in a linear fashion it's
like a movie I'm very familiar with over
time but you haven't actually fully
watched did you know how it ended yeah
well no no well not all of it not all of
the context but I knew some of the
elements of how it ended yeah
interesting I just want to get that
cleared up well and also I mean because
this is a Hays Code movie you can
theoretically draw some conclusions
about how it's going to end anyway well
I decided to watch the theatrical cut
the one that most people are familiar
with because we had an option on watch
three versions one was the 1958 version
the other one was the thing is 70s
version which was the first cut I
believe that Orson Welles sent over to
them because what they did was they
ended up Rishi
a lot of scenes of with a different
director so it wasn't the cut that Orson
Welles had final approval over that went
into the cinemas that became a classic
funny enough and then I thinking that it
was I'm not sure if I'm getting the
decades right but I believe it was the
90s when there was a director and editor
who had all the notes that Orson Welles
had of how he thought the movie should
be edited with all the footage and he
Mesa Lee made the Orson Welles cut and
even though there was this whole lawsuit
thing that occurred his daughter said
that this was the version Orson Welles
wanted because there was a time where
she was like she's suing them for not
getting her final approval on it but
then when she eventually saw it she was
like yeah this is actually what my dad
would have wanted which is pretty cool
we only watch the theatrical version so
I didn't want to get too caught up in
the Orson Welles rendition I know this
is based on a novel edge of evil yeah I
have been read the novel only sin the
one movie and you know tell you guys
really quick I really enjoyed it I
thought it was a cool movie really easy
to pay attention to
I loved the immediacy of it and the
pacing was really neat too well it has a
lot for a classic movie it has a lot of
very modern earmarks especially in a lot
of the shot choices and the lenses and
stuff like that
yeah the modern-day cinematography
element to it I felt like inspiration
then maybe perhaps like De Palma or
Tarantino might have taken from this
sort of direction I feel like I tend to
feel that way when I watch a Hitchcock
film or an Orson Welles movie is these
certain modern-day earmarks that
filmmakers that we love today actually
borrow from oh yeah these like really
strong angles and moving camera shots
and stuff like that there was a lot that
watching this and especially the parts I
hadn't seen were surprising me with the
the way they were shooting it yeah with
that being said I you know a lot of
times these classic movies you always at
the factor and the time in which they
came out and how it probably held up to
that standard of then and for me I I
felt like when I put myself in the time
of when it came out it was probably as
close to perfect as you can get when I
watch it today I it was
easy for me to think of some things that
if you were to redo this how to perhaps
improve upon a few things I think first
off the Miguel Mike Vargas character
that was played by Charlton Heston you
should keep him white you should keep a
white actor in a wider act a wider actor
I'm Wyatt Russell I think would be a
great choice to play Mexican drug
enforcement official Miguel Vargas yeah
I think you should keep his hair blonde
too don't even guys yeah it's like I
think that's your first bet yeah and but
then make the Orson Welles character
Quinlan Captain Quinlan make him Mexican
and yes I'm really confused that's thick
Mexican access really diverse cast going
on but not pay attention to where we're
putting any of those actors I I'm firm
for me and before I go into like you
know recasting because that was actually
the last thing I was like really
concerned about we were doing this
podcast you know I think like the Orson
Welles character you know I sure John
Goodman my to go throw him in there
who's the coolest overweight actor right
now he's a great pick you know get a
real Mexican actor to play McHale our
users there's many to choose from now
and I'm sure we have some specific
choices the thing with the movie that I
wear I think it can improve upon is
honestly just what leads into the plot I
think this is where people will probably
have a disagreement with me on this
because I like the immediacy I like the
the awesome opening shot that the film
has I would probably start it a little
outlet act one breathe more and let the
car explosion be in your break into act
2 if we were to redo this because I
honestly wasn't hooked into this film
until it got to the part if you guys
haven't only gonna be four people have
seen touching people but there's the
element where the plot really kicks into
high gear when Quinlin plant some
dynamite in a suspect shoe box showing
that you know
a crooked cop he's setting this guy up
and that's when I was like okay I'm in
now I'm hooked into this movie whereas
like as cool as the shots were and as
good as the acting was I I really wasn't
engrossed until that moment finally came
into play so I thought what would I do
to make everything and all those
sequences those plot points prior to
that engrossing is I would really lean
into setting up our characters a little
bit more I think it'd be like kind of a
cool homage if you're you know spending
a little bit more time with Mike and
Susan Vargas newlyweds really getting to
know them and spend time with them
because for me Janet Lee's character
Susan bargah sort of felt like a plot
device here
as a lot of female characters in
classical be something to as a damsel in
distress characters to create tension
and stakes for our lead to deal with for
a male lead character and like even
though I thought she does a great job in
the movie I did feel in terms of a
writing perspective and a directing
perspective that's what she was mainly
utilized for and I would just feel more
pulled into I would feel the danger and
stakes and more of the mystery element
if there was a better setup to the
situation really establishing that
border divide between Mexico and the US
and how it's just one walk away right
and like how on this one strip that if
you just walk through that border it's a
whole different world really showing the
US and like oh it's beautiful here but
on this side of Mexico right here the
border etchants this is where it's
really crime centric yeah well and
there's also to just the general snafu
that is a bomb being transported over
the border and then blowing up on
American soil and so I feel like the
context parts of that for me it's like
you have this really beautiful opening
shot that is so immediate and is really
well-crafted but at the same time I feel
like some of the context could be a
little more clear because especially
nowadays if that particular scenario
were to happen it would be a political
shitstorm and so I feel like in remaking
this in general you
would have just so much to work with
with the tensions between the US and
Mexico the tensions about the border all
that stuff and yeah I mean I feel like
the political element you could
theoretically get deeper into for the
movie as a whole because this is like a
very effective
you know noir detective or not detective
Lee you know we're figuring out a
mystery genres anymore yeah exactly and
so I feel like if yeah definitely if you
were going to Ramaiya it's just all the
more relevant to dive into those
tensions yeah I think you could do one
of those things where because there's a
couple that is in that car that explodes
and the thing is I have zero emotional
investment in any of these characters
yeah until that moment with the shoebox
happens where I'm like okay now I'm in
gross wonder nice and that's them that's
the layer that I think if you set up
your characters really you could even
have Captain Quinlan come in like 30
minutes into the film at the same point
I really feel like you can pretty much
do the same movie in terms of plot
points just have a better expanded act
one I think would be pretty cool before
you get to the car explosion where you
pay tribute to the the one shot and you
kind of expect that shot even longer or
expand upon it and stuff and that way
you're pulled into you know who's in
that car if you feel like oh [ __ ] that
sucks you know or whatever emotion
supposed to feel for those people who
died that way you know the you know the
players better before the game starts
happening yeah and maybe I mean you know
a way to kind of smooth that out because
yeah I think it might be interesting to
not just I feel like it would be kind of
obvious if you redid Touch of Evil just
just immediately open on that shot and I
feel like bringing it in slightly later
would be a nice thing because it gives
people something to anticipate and I
think you could make a fun game out of
like the first image is somebody turns
into frame with that bomb and then the
clock and everything and I feel like you
could even in a clever visual way kind
of hint and tease at the presence of
this person you know through without
their opening moments and then you know
that shot kicks off so we've already got
you know attention percolating yeah
so really it's it's mainly the act one
scenario
who that I would change yeah this is a
1995 minute film I think the theatrical
cut the one that most people have seen
and so I'm you like I don't know what
the expansion cuts are I think they all
start with that one shot or a very
immediate from my understanding because
I think even or some Welles his final
cut that he was wanted to make it was
the same shot but just with no music it
just feels like that was what they yeah
it feels like that wasn't always
intended to be the opening it's it's the
complete setup of the movie it's here's
yeah the murder weapon here is the
situation and all we have removed is
whodunit yeah and it's also what was the
the grah grah see is that the oh yeah
the grassy King or I don't know I mean
it was like uncle uncle something right
yeah let me find a name here killing
time on Randy Randy grandi okay yeah
like when there's that's a that's the
villainous gang that you're dealing with
in the movie and you could really ask
you could really build that up that way
you're not just because they're kind of
being thrown into so much in the first
half of this movie before you have time
to let your emotions settle in so and I
think you can't improve the Janet Lee
character to be more than just plot
device or at least have more investment
in her that way you you care more well
just give her more of her own autonomy
because especially when she gets to the
motel there's so much time spent with
her basically just doing the same thing
over and over which is you know like
being on the phone being dismayed by
them blasting the music and that is a
tense situation but I feel like yeah in
a remake you might want to definitely
expand on that character and give her
more things to to do make her and Mike
even though they're so far removed from
each other for a lot of the plot feel
like some kind of team yeah you know
rather than yeah just her being
incidental and and completely caught in
this car I feels complaining about new
yeah yeah I think you could update her
you know female characters have changed
a lot over time and I feel like you
could update her a good amount and I do
it's funny cuz I'm I agree about the
beginning and I feel like you could
finesse out the ending a lot a bit as
well because old movies what I've often
noticed is like once you wrap up the
plot there's like a few
lines and the movies and that's an
interesting thing to me because I feel
like movies have also changed in a sense
where we wrap up the plot and then we
wrap up the characters whereas older
movies to me kind of do it in Reverse
yeah so you know I feel like there are
certain things you could smooth there
and also to just the cultural aspects
you know you you have aside from getting
better casting on Charlton Heston I feel
like you could do some some interesting
things with the grandi family perhaps
you know and I don't know the war on
drugs and all this stuff like there
there's so much just socio-political
context you can draw from so I don't
know if I would want to make this like a
Sicario kind of toned movie but I feel
like you can also you know draw in a lot
of those tensions - well what I was
gonna say is I think the environment
should be felt yeah there's some there's
a lack of you know I like what we do a
modern-day cinema in terms of when you
feel the world you feel the city and you
know back then you didn't really get the
opportunity to lend itself to such mood
and atmosphere back then with that
Mexico more of a character yeah exactly
I want this that's what I meant upfront
by having the border really established
beyond just the political standpoint but
really showing that these are two
different worlds that are segregated by
just being able to walk past it yeah and
then that day you're in a completely
different world because you know for the
most part they look kind of like Cameron
unless they're saying they're in Mexico
you can't really tell they're Mexico you
know yeah and and I think - the one
thing that did strike me there is a
thrown out there a line towards the end
of the movie where we solve the mystery
and they say or ostensibly they're
basically like yeah the guy confessed
and and what that made me think of
because there is such a mystery in this
movie about who's telling the truth who
planted the evidence is the planted
evidence complete falsehood or is it
just to push the law along we have a lot
of problems right now with police
misconduct and I feel like there's a lot
you can to do with that but you also
have I think in modern times a
discussion about torture and confessions
and stuff
that and so when they have that moment
where they're like he confessed I guess
he really did do it for me for whatever
reason that didn't ultimately equate to
it a narrative satisfaction I was sort
of like well what happened at the
interrogation we didn't see it was he
coerced you know what so I feel like you
could also dive deeper beyond the police
corruption - things like that - with it
but I think this movie for its time and
the immediacy of it works really well
for what you for what you get that is
presented on screen I think for a remake
there things that you could dive into to
make this feel more gritty and feel more
real like if there were to remake this I
would less like you know film noir talk
and really try to capture what they
might talk like back then you know I
think it would be cool to still have to
keep it in this period but explore that
time kind of like a better version of
what Public Enemies is trying to do you
know more along the lines of a Bonnie
and Clyde than than a touch would be
like I like Bonnie and Clyde a lot
because it takes place in a very
specific time period and yet it still
felt very authentic it still has some of
the Hollywood earmark dialogue but I
feel like making more real but with like
with it like more of an Aaron Sorkin
type of type of dialogue to it cuz I
feel like Aaron Sorkin's kind of rhythm
works well for a film noir I'm the type
of story especially here one thing I
thought was really cool was when they're
all like kind of getting on each other's
asses when there's a group of people in
this in the movie like with a shoebox
scene or like Quinlan's going like
everyone's just like all gather around
the same thing everyone's talking over
each other and I feel like that's rare
in these classic movies but I mean but I
would want to play a little bit more
into the chaos and let the emotional
paranoia and the intensity really build
over time in that you're kind of cutting
around - a lot in this movie and easily
the most compelling character was
Quinlan I would want to enhance the the
personal conflict that this creates for
Miguel Vargas and why he feels because
he just seems like I'm just doing the
right thing you know
that's all his character is and that is
a very classic and I wonder too if that
if what the characters like in the book
because again this does fall under the
Hays Code and so if he's gonna make it
out at the end he has to pretty much be
just an upstanding moral character and
so that's definitely something that yeah
I would want to see in a in a remake of
this is give him just a little more
flesh a little more life a little more
gray yeah so you know I would have mind
it being a little bit more are like have
more swear words that you have to go
like freaking like gory your violin one
of the characters runs a brothel
yeah exactly like yeah yeah there's like
strippers and stuff in here that's what
I mean like really
instead of like Hollywood black and
white flashy classic film noir make it
more of a you still make it stylistic
but more authentic in terms of how it
was not how Hollywood was trying to
portray that time yeah one if it was me
too I would I would perhaps I loved what
you said about you know the people
talking over each other and playing up
on those tensions more and one thing I
thought is you know Miguel is often
outnumbered by people who were you know
with Quinlan in his program and stuff
like that so I might even go so far as
just stylistically to play up the space
between people the tension in what
people are gonna notice and stuff like
that I didn't really feel the weight of
Miguel that was falling on his shoulders
until you know of course plot devices
kidnapped it you know well yeah cuz it's
like he kind of noted this isn't his
situation but he does realize what a
problem it's gonna become so it kind of
involves myself early on in the movie
when they do before the shoe box thing
happens he's like this is him
this is America this isn't my territory
I don't belong here he says that like
and he seems like he's just like I'm
ready to walk away from the case mm-hm
and then he just gets involved it does
the right thing and I I think that you
you would be better to build the wait
the the fact that he is essentially the
outsider in this situation he's got
these of essentially racist American
cops who are on his ass at least
Quinlan's racist thing he's got these
guys who are and like he he know I want
to feel that weight that he's deal
with and if that they do go with the
wife being kidnapped in that situation
that should just be the thing that
pushes him to the edge yeah but he
should already be being pushed yeah yeah
and then also make his relationship with
Schwartz that much you know more
impactful cuz I like their dynamic in
the movie and if you had yeah just more
intensity and more grave for Miguel to
deal with that could make the Schwartz
character very much a relief you know
very much the one other character that
you're kind of happy to see each time he
pops up cuz he's probably the one
character who Miguel has throughout the
movie to kind of identify whether rely
on you know and I oh they're all I
really have no complaint with the the
way they'd handle any of Quinlin in the
movie cuz to me he was the best part
he's so natural like I was sitting here
watching this wondering if that was just
how Orson Welles was at the time or if
these were character choices but you
know what there's this one thing I would
I wish we got more of and I was at
Marlene Dietrich is Tanja they hinted at
it like they have this one scene where
like Oh doesn't air a mystery in history
here and that cuts to later and they
read my tarot card like so briefly lived
yeah and I really feel like if they were
willing to because of the place that she
runs the brothel yeah I think and their
history and their history but you know I
think they kind of intentionally kept
him away from the brothel scenes and I
would have I wouldn't have minded a
little bit more expansion on dialogue
that's what I mean by Aaron Sorkin
because he's so heavy with the dialogue
yeah it's always so gripping and sudden
so rhythmic that I think like literally
an r-rated Sorkin script expanded Act
one more person expanded Act one would
instantly lend itself to a more and
easier to set up scenario of an
emotional intensity for Miguel's
character and Susan barkis's character
and then yeah probably a better ending
button as opposed to what threads do we
need to wrap up there you go say to the
audience yeah this is something like
that in terms of casting I guess
or I this might sound cliche because
only a couple of really well-known
Mexican actors today but I I don't even
know this guy's Mexican but I think
Pedro Pascal would obviously be the
perfect choice between those three that
come to mind Pedro Pascal as though is
definitely the one for me
for that choice DJ cotrona TJ katroo
yeah like Pedro rides out of like fine
line his work on our narco so you know
he's played cops before can already
imagine him with a moustache yeah it's
pretty simple yeah for the Susan Vargas
character margot robbie that is actually
uh not a bad cliche pick it's gonna be a
bad reference but the only one i can
specifically as Scott Pilgrim she's the
drummer but she's played older timey
aunjanue types since then and she's
gotten like she's not like incredibly
young but she's not also yet in her like
middle age so I feel like you know being
the younger wife of somebody she could
be a pretty appropriate she's blonde
yeah good point
Marlene Dietrich Tanja who has like a
sexy weirdly the one thing I wasn't kind
of thinking about much was the cast
weirdly I don't know why but for some
reason the first face that popped into
my mind was you know a woman who played
the mom in an Appel creation there no we
Georgian of evil I'm sorry the who runs
the girl's home she's on she's one of
the leads in the haunting of Hill House
and I know face does not quite come to
mind thank you I cannot for the life of
me remember her name but in a way when I
think just on the look of that character
on Marlena Dietrich character I her face
came to my mind I was like I mean she
can do it you know just a terrific
actress too so well there you go those
are the main ones yeah and then cast
John Turturro as Schwartz sure
anyway that's how if they were to ever
remake Touch of Evil a film that they
probably should never remake it's
probably good pretty much just like add
on an act one mostly just remake it
flesh a little couple things out and
then it's good enough actually okay
you're essentially making the same movie
you know yeah similar plot because I
think the plot points are great and I
think the plot point like there's
nothing really wrong with the plot
points form I like how they keep sort of
out I like how smart Quinlan is too even
though he seems like you know it's
probably easier now with this guy he's
like angry and drunk like that you can't
he's also more than just as crazy
intimidating physique he's got brains
well there is that magical intimidating
or not intimidating but just kind of
disheartening note that like well he
does these bad things but at least in
this case it appears as though he was
right so like then you starts yeah just
opens up you should never plant evidence
but it is an interesting thing to wonder
about like well is he just always right
does he have that good of a notion for
crime well yeah yeah were they saying he
was right the guy who he planted the
dynamite on yeah at the end they say he
confessed to the crime Quinlan was right
you know and and that was to me I was
like well I want to see the confession
there are a lot of ways you can coerce
what you want to hear out of people oh
is I wasn't sure if that meant Quinlan
was right or the guy was just so
quartered he felt like he just had to
well yeah that's why to me it wasn't
that bit of information wasn't like a
satisfying piece of information cuz it
just gave me questions I had that exact
like did he say this just to get you to
stop doing what did he just decide cuz
he puts up such a convincing protest in
the room and he was free yeah that he
was framed and it makes sense that he'd
be framed and then all this time being
like Quinlan you had 17 sticks of
dynamite and yeah he did frame him but I
guess yeah the movie at least implies
perhaps that he was correct in his
assumption of this man's guilt and I
said of Quinlan having a game like I
make it a game dick yeah his dick is
doesn't work that's why he's always a
problem because it's like well if I can
get it you know at least I can soak in
the musk you know all right guys well
how would you remake Touch of Evil
comment below do you like our idea let's
get like a twenty minute for a long drug
trip sequence just make this like fear
and loathing but with you know more
crime subscribe click that notification
bell David thanks for requesting this
man keep with the martial arts talked a
lot about it don't overstretch watches
in her hamstrings it's easy to tear
something if you over stretch and a guy
in your age you think you're 105 you got
to be very mindful of that drink your
milk to get those bones strong oh yeah
yeah really get that calcium like
commercial when the guy was wheel
bearing something in his arms came off I
think I remember this vaguely and yeah
it's about it's about like milk helps
make bone strong osteoporosis oh I'm
gonna have to look up so oh those old
milk ads man they went really far to get
us to drink that stuff never worked hate
milk see